what do you really know about vin diesel
we all know he's the star of the fast
and furious movies not to mention the
voice of groot
but there's still so much about the
performer that isn't common knowledge
here are some little-known facts about
vin diesel
diesel's love for the craft of acting
was instilled in him at a young age
at the tender age of seven diesel born
mark sinclair debuted as a performer in
a stage play called
dinosaur door his original intentions
however were somewhat different
according to a cnn profile he and his
brother broke into theater for the new
city in manhattan's east village hoping
to wreck it in an act of rebellion
these plans were quickly foiled once
they were caught by the venue's artistic
director
crystal field who gave them a chance to
appear in the play
they gladly accepted and diesel's first
acting gig was locked down
little did diesel know that day that
this was the first step in an acting
career that would span
decades and multiple billion dollar
worldwide hits
iconic performers can come from anywhere
including vandals turned inadvertent
actors in productions of dinosaur door
vin diesel is nowadays known as the face
of the fast and furious franchise as
well as the voice of groot in a series
of marvel cinematic universe movies
but when he first engaged in the art of
cinema vin diesel wasn't just acting in
smaller scale fare he was also working
as a director
though he hasn't stepped behind the
camera in more than a decade
diesel's first notable project was the
1995 short film
multi-facial i'm not really into doing
soaps i'll be honest with you
it's not my idea really acting you know
what i mean
you got to make a living diesel also
starred
penned the screenplay and composed the
score reflecting the intense passion he
had for this endeavor
the 27-minute film was submitted to the
cannes film festival where it garnered a
strong acclaim
it also paved the way for diesel to
direct the 1997 feature-length movie
strays
though his first few projects showed
that diesel wanted to be a director his
career would end up focusing almost
exclusively on being a leading man in
movies that would be a far cry from his
more grounded indie endeavors
while that career change has resulted in
a number of memorable characters
it's also a far cry from the more
challenging intimate dramas diesel
helmed early on
while the fast and the furious was the
movie that propelled diesel to the
a-list a year prior to that car-oriented
action movie
diesel scored his actual start as a
leading man that beginning came with
pitch black a low-budget sci-fi movie
that served as the debut for diesel's
famous character
riddick this production wasn't meant to
be the start of a major leading man's
career
it was initially just another sci-fi
horror film trying to squeeze a few
dollars out of moviegoers in between
bigger blockbusters in february
however you never know what's going to
resonate with people and pitch black
ended up being more successful than
expected with a 53.1 million dollar
worldwide total
in the process mainstream audiences got
their first extensive glimpse at diesel
who firmly established his commanding
screen persona with his work here
diesel would go on to star in bigger
movies as soon as one year later with
the fast and the furious but despite the
success of that
par-filled feature pitch black was the
motion picture that secured diesel's
leading man status
some actors live for the spotlight while
others will do anything to shy away from
it when they're not filming a project
vin diesel is decidedly in the latter
camp despite headlining major hollywood
movies for over two decades
diesel isn't a staple of the tabloids
and much of his personal life remains a
mystery
diesel has made it apparent in
interviews that this is very much a
conscious choice
in 2006 after being asked about his
romantic relationships diesel told
details magazine i'm not going to put it
out there on a magazine cover like some
other actors
i come from the harrison ford marlon
brando robert de niro al pacino code of
silence
he would then go on to note that he
prefers exploring romantic relationships
in europe because he's a little more
incognito there
since that interview diesel has remained
true to his words although those
following his social media feeds like
his instagram get occasional glimpses
into his personal world
diesel has largely stayed out of the
limelight unless he's talking about his
artistic pursuits
the continued aura of mysteries
surrounding diesel is a testament to how
he's maintained that code of silence
about his personal life for so long
what does ven diesel do when he's not
starring in movies chances are he's
playing dungeons and dragons this
tabletop game is a favorite for the
actor
and it's influenced a number of the
movies he's appeared in in particular
the chronicles of riddick is one of the
biggest reflections of diesel's affinity
for d d
with this sequel the world of pitch
black was expanded to include
dense lore that was largely inspired by
d d this creative influence wasn't
limited to what happened on screen
it even impacted what the actors did on
the set diesel told underground online
i was literally playing dungeons and
dragons with judy dench and carl urban
at nights after shooting chronicles of
riddick
i will tell you that i was showing her
dungeons and dragons books and showing
her the different properties of
elementals
diesel's love for this game would go on
to be a massive source of inspiration
for his 2015 film
the last witch hunter to the point that
the movie's protagonist is just a
slightly tweaked version of diesel's own
d d character
and that's all before getting into how
diesel penned the introduction to the
book 30 years of adventure
a celebration of dungeons and dragons
in the mid-2000s diesel decided to get
in on the ground floor of the booming
video game industry by starting up his
own production company dedicated to
making games
the label was called taigon studios and
represented an attempt by diesel to both
have more control of the products he was
associated with and to get in on a
rapidly expanding market
tygon studios head ian stevens told game
industry.biz
it really is just about a guy who loves
games wanting to find a way for
hollywood and the games industry to find
more interesting ways to work together
than they typically do
stevens also noted that diesel has had a
long-standing love for the video game
industry
in the years since its launch taigon
studios hasn't always lived up to its
potential with some of its biggest
initial titles like
wheel man failing to really take off
however that doesn't mean tygon has
totally flamed out
in fact in spite of all the ways the
video game industry has changed in the
last 15 years
tygon studios is still in existence and
was credited as one of the developers on
the 2020 video game
fast and furious crossroads in the fall
of 2020 vin diesel began pursuing a new
avenue for artistic expression
having already done films and video
games and even showing up to croon tunes
at special events
diesel was now becoming a singer
apparently a response to the
restrictions imposed on him by covet 19
diesel had found a new outlet for
creative expression that didn't entail
gathering up countless cast and crew
members for a film shoot
his debut single was entitled feel like
i do and was followed up by the tune
days are gone diesel premiered his songs
on the kelly clarkson show where they
garnered lots of attention but generated
a mixed response from the internet at
large
still even if they weren't universally
beloved diesel's songs have a special
place in his heart
diesel explained to clarkson i am
blessed that in a year that i would
normally be on a movie set
and as you know that's not possible i've
had another creative outlet
another way to show you or share with
you my heart though diesel hasn't
officially announced how extensively
he'll pursue singing in the future
the obviously personal place these tunes
are coming from makes it a short bet we
haven't seen the last of vin diesel the
singer
everyone's aware that diesel can drive a
car really fast but did you know that
diesel is also a skilled brake dancer
it's a gift that diesel employed in his
earliest days as an artist in new york
city where he would perform on the
streets in between shifts as a bouncer
though diesel has clearly moved on to
much bigger things than having to dance
for cash
videos of diesel's break dancing moves
are still around online and give a
glimpse into his talents in this form
diesel himself has been reminded of this
part of his career several times
throughout the years
including in a 2014 appearance on live
with kelly and michael much to diesel's
amusing discomfort
in that appearance diesel commented this
was back
in the 80s yeah i used to break dance at
columbus circle i used to break dance at
washington square park it was my first
gig
the way diesel described this experience
makes it clear that though we shouldn't
expect to see breakdancing as a plot
point in any future fast and furious
movies he
still looks back on this part of his
life with some degree of fondness
the role of pug in the ben affleck
action movie reindeer games is not
a significant role but it is one vin
diesel was originally slated to play
yet anyone who's seen the final cut of
that film knows that pug was played by
donald logue
how did the character go from being
portrayed by diesel to logue danny trejo
revealed in a 2010 interview with the av
club that he helped convince diesel to
walk away from the film
and star in the fast and the furious
instead diesel expanded on this matter
in 2015 when he revealed to uprocks that
a primary reason for him ditching the
film was creative disputes with director
john frankenheimer
in the process he didn't just miss out
on the role he also lost a 500 000
payday but by walking away from the film
entirely diesel gave himself the
opportunity to headline the career
changing the fast and the furious
we've all got to start somewhere that's
even true for vin diesel whose movies
have amassed a combined
11.1 billion dollars worldwide
even a performer of this caliber didn't
begin his acting career
firing on all cylinders in fact his very
first job opportunity when he arrived in
los angeles wasn't an acting gig at all
but rather a job in the world of
telemarketing diesel told the new york
times
well the first time i went to hollywood
i couldn't even get an agent
i got to la and i auditioned a bunch but
i couldn't get an agent i ended up
telemarketing
selling tools over the phone clearly
diesel left that life behind once he got
the chance to direct ann's star in
movies
however his skills at selling people
things did end up having some level of
influence over his life
as it laid the groundwork for how diesel
has become a one-man hype machine on
social media
for his various artistic pursuits that's
the kind of confident salesman attitude
you can only glean from extensive
telemarketing experience
for a while inhumans was a part of the
phase 3 slate for the marvel cinematic
universe with the project first set for
a november 2018 release before moving to
july 2019
in the earliest days of this
production's existence rumors spread
like wildfire that vin diesel was on tap
to play the lead of the film
blackbolt diesel later confirmed these
rumors though he noted that
even with his existing connections with
marvel through playing the character
groot
diesel was only looking to play black
bolt if the inhumans movie looked
appealing
diesel explained to mtv it's not a
matter of me wooing marvel it's a matter
of marvel
wooing me and i love them but i'm just
saying show me a dope script and show me
a great director
all of which i know that kevin feige is
capable of
that process of wooing was cut short
when marvel studios took the inhumans
movie off their release schedule and
marvel television announced plans to do
a separate inhumans tv show
this seemed to be the end of the
inhumans movie and the prospect of
seeing diesel as black vault
even with the film shelved diesel
continued to openly campaign for marvel
to do an inhumans movie as late as
january 2020.
for the moment though the inhumans movie
and diesel's chance to take on a second
marvel cinematic universe role have been
put on a shelf
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite action stars are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you